- Hi, I'm Lucy Hale,
and I am about to play
BuzzFeed's toughest game
of Would You Rather.
Let's do this.
Alright, would you rather
be forced to wear wet socks
for the rest of your life,
or be allowed to wash your
hair only once a year?
Honestly, like wearing
wet socks is pretty awful.
I don't really like washing my hair,
so I think I'd choose to wash
my hair for only once a year.
I'd get some dread locks going on.
It'd be pretty cool.
Would you rather have
a finger as a tongue,
or have tongues as fingers?
I mean, could my finger taste?
Because then it'd still
kinda be like a tongue.
Or would it be like I feel-
Well, this is like a brain, okay.
Have tongues as fingers.
Maybe have tongues as
fingers 'cause then you could
taste more.
But then you'd taste
everything you touched.
But I like tasting things,
so I'll still go with that.
Would you rather wear someone
else's dirty underwear?
Hell, no.
Or use someone else's toothbrush?
Honestly, I'm never wearing
someone else's dirty underwear.
I'll use someone else's
toothbrush any day.
Would you rather shit
bricks, or puke slugs?
I mean shitting bricks,
literally, sounds painful.
Like really painful.
So I'm gonna go with puke slugs,
because that's the better of the two.
Would you rather pee yourself
in public once a week,
or shit yourself in private daily?
Probably shit myself privately
daily, 'cause who cares?
We've probably all done it anyway.
Would you rather always
have to tell the truth,
or always lie?
Why is this one the hardest for me?
Probably always tell the truth.
Actually, I'd get myself
into so much trouble,
so, yeah, we'll go with that.
We'll be an honest Abe.
Would you rather never
have internet access again,
or never be able to take
an airplane anywhere again?
Probably never be able to take
an airplane anywhere again.
I'm cool with that.
Would you rather have your body found
in a pile of sex toys,
or have everyone you know
see your browsing history?
Like, I'm dead and I'm
found in a pile of sex toys?
I got nothing to hide.
People can see my browsing
history, that's fine with me.
Would you rather be in
a real life version of
American Horror Story,
or be in the real life
version of The Walking Dead?
American Horror Story, probably,
just 'cause I like that show more.
Would you rather only be
able to whisper everything,
or only be able to shout
everything? (laughs)
Probably whisper.
Would you rather run your
tongue down a New York
City sidewalk,
or press your tongue into
a stranger's nostril?
I guess down a New York City sidewalk.
Would you rather find true
love or win the lottery?
Win the lottery.
And that's it.
Would you rather with
Lucy Hale and BuzzFeed.